[Musica]
abbiamo sentito pascal benaglia il
nostro bike trial i sta che questa sera
ci darà una dimostrazione vuole entrare
in scena proprio dalla nostra scala e
quindi lo invito a muovere le prime
pedalate su questa dimostrazione pascal
benaglia è diplomato in educazione
fisica e docente di educazione fisica
scienza del movimento e all'ambizione a
breve di attivare una palestra proprio
per la formazione la sua iniziativa il
suo performance è legata proprio alla
demo di questa disciplina legate al
mondo del ciclismo legata all'unione
ciclistica internazionale ci darà
dimostrazione di quelle che sono alcune
abilità che si esercitano in questo
sport in questa disciplina nel suo
passato ci sono dei titoli a livello
nazionale mondiale e anche europeo
e noi funzioniamo così proprio con gli
applausi perché questo è il modo di
motivarci
[Musica]
questa posizione è detta di palleggio
serve proprio di pica per mantenere
l'equilibrio sulla ruota posteriore che
permette un controllo migliore del mezzo
a noi è stato chiesto di dare una
dimostrazione proprio nell'aspetto di
ostacoli quelli che solitamente questa
la intro di pascal quegli ostacoli che
solitamente ci prendono durante le
nostre attività giornaliere quotidiane
ostacoli che anche per i nostri giovani
certe volte sono significativi il
controllo sempre sulla ruota posteriore
di pascal benaglia questo è una delle
prerogative per controllare questo mezzo
ci si esibisce proprio senza sella anche
perché permette di alleggerire il mezzo
meccanico un salto laterale
oggi nuovo caschiamo
il bike trial ha l'ambizione di essere
metafora di vita metafora di resilienza
di superare le crisi superare gli
ostacoli che giornalmente incappano ad
esempio come questo primo tentativo e
l'applauso del pubblico che ringrazio te
ed ex lugano
[Musica]
ok
questa è la simulazione
[Musica]
la crisi seguiteci con le nostre slate
anche
[Musica]
non c'è
troviamo un piano b troviamo il metodo
per andare oltre all'ostacolo che la
vita
in realtà ci propone noi lo si molliamo
con lo sport
[Musica]
sto prevede pascal ce l'abbiamo fatta
ulteriore la tonale l'appoggio con la
ruota anteriore la tecnica
vogliamo sulla parte più alta
[Musica]
e andiamo a cercare le complicazioni le
prestazioni quella parte legata al
difficile
[Musica]
e l'equilibrio
due metri e 80 circa
[Musica]
questo capita
[Applauso]
eravamo pascal
mi avvicino un attimo mi avvicino un
attimo per chiederti alcune cose nella
disciplina del bike trial tu sappiamo
che sei anche allenatore della
federazione svizzera di ciclismo
la swiss cycling sei responsabili delle
categorie giovanili
qual è prendi fiato certo parlo così
almeno le frequenze cardiache si calmano
quali sono le prerogative che sono
richieste questi ragazzi per iniziare
per partecipare a questa disciplina ma
sicuramente è importantissimo la forza
equilibrio come avete visto
concentration sua importante because you
just one la concentrazione perché la
maggior parte rho alte sia solo un
tentativo e se si sbaglia si arriva
secondi terzi eccetera e tanto
entusiasmo tanta costanza
nell'allenamento come avete potuto
vedere nelle slide pesce passion fruit
because it right rai 3 game to face
tianyu suckle new eight eccetera
e l'applauso del pubblico sottolinea
sicuramente la tua iniziativa e la tua
prestazione
vi ringraziamo fedex lugano 2019 buona
continuazione
buon divertimento grazie pascal grazie
pubblico
[Applauso]